bonjour shoukria haïdar merci d'être
avec nous ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france alors vous avez vous-même
suit il ya plusieurs années
l'afghanistan aujourd'hui depuis la
prise de kaboul par les dalits banque
est ce que vous craignez pour les femmes
peut-être des femmes que vous connaissez
encore aujourd'hui quel futur quel
quotidien se profile pour l
écouter
bonjour à tous
impliqués pour s'exprimer sur la
situation des femmes dégoûtées
cession des ports bien entendu pour
toutes ces femmes qui sont à l'intérieur
mais c'est l'endroit dans toutes les
villes partout où ils ont gagné dans d
autres monnaies les gars à la maison
elles ont été toutes ces
exactions
le faire mariage avec laure seulement
tenté d'entrer dans
le musée par ça donc il
[Musique]
faut dire qu'il
la voyait pratiquement la majorité total
de ces droits des sans elles sont
menacées
clermont soleil c'est pareil ça prend
une parole mais je t'ai dit le
représentant de l'état les banques et
notre roi bien on doit
pas bon ça veut dire le chien vous avez
des chariots en italien plusieurs
différends mais les yeux c'est les plus
durs de plus c'est difficile
déjà l'intervention de li l'interdiction
de sortir son
est bien là qu'ont payé et le travail
parce que dans certains secteurs qui
étaient nécessaires oui avec de bons
justement les talibans ils ont assuré
que les femmes pour retravailler quand
la sécurité sera assurée est ce que vous
les croyez si oui dans quelles
conditions ces femmes travailleront n'en
pas douter le crois pas parce que la
sécurité mais c'est la sécurité qui
étaient comme m il n'est pas notre
intégrité
c'est la sécurité venu de la room de
leur
nez de l'europe la paire à 15
cm mais à part celle ci n'est pas un
petit coup d les confessions entre eux
et leur vécu dans le passé et
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de problèmes
entre les besoins
c'est noël
et pour cela vous est elle peut pas
croire sur ces départs on est alors le
lot n uds à
l'onu a dit que la ligne à ne pas
franchir c'est justement là cette
condition des femmes pour le moment on
n'y a rien de concret de prévu mais est
ce que cette pression de la communauté
internationale
elle peut fonctionner sur les talibans
en tout les cas il faut que ça
fonctionne et il faut que la mairie
l'amérique est procédé à ses
responsabilités la douleur car c'est
vers la guérison les accords qu'ils
avaient en bouche en cachette des années
de professionnalisme et aujourd'hui même
avec tous ces parents qu'ils avaient des
ailes à résultats en application on le
voit dans l'aéroport ailleurs on est au
courant de rien
de rien et de nulle part il y ait
personne pour témoigner tout tout est
bloqué
c'était ça la voix de
l'est cette manière de
réguler par toutes les unités et je
passe devant la force
les militaires au pouvoir
guerrier détail ou volontairement en
faire tomber les unes après les autres
merci beaucoup si trillard d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
franc je rappelle vous êtes présidente
de l'association negar soutien aux
femmes d'afghanistan